It wasn't easy for Christian Bale to prepare
for director James Mangold's Ford v Ferrari,
but it was worth the effort.
Looper recently spoke with Ford v Ferrari
stunt coordinator Robert Nagle about how he
made the veteran actor road-ready.
Here's the truth behind Bale's intense training
for the pic.
To teach Bale how to drive like a real racer,
Nagle sent the former Dark Knight to the Bondurant
High Performance Driving School in Arizona.
For seven days, Bale spent seven hours on
the track, learning how to drive thanks to
lessons from Nagle's hand-picked instructor.
But that was only part of Bale's education,
and there was a reason why Boundurant was
the place Bale did his first phase of Ford
v Ferrari prep.
Nagle explained:
"Part of the reason I picked Bondurant [was
that] Bob Bondurant was an icon from that
era and was a big part of that GT40 program."
Two years before Ken Miles' history-making
performance at the 1966 automobile event,
racecar driver Bob Bondurant completed 334
laps at the 1964 24 Hours of Le Mons.
Like Miles, Bondurant was driving a car designed
by Carroll Shelby, the engineer whom Matt
Damon plays in Ford v Ferrari.
"Just shut your mouth and let me do my thing.
Alright."
It was enough to win the GT class at the event,
but not the overall race.
Naturally, a Ferrari came in first.
For a full week, Bondurant regaled Bale and
Nagle with stories from the Ford v Ferrari
era of the mid-1960s.
Nagle estimated that Bale and Bondurant chatted
for four or five hours a day.
To Nagle's surprise, Bondurant was also close
friends with Miles, and had plenty of insights
to share about the late star.
Nagle dished:
"The information that [Bale was] able to get
from Bob was amazing.
It was an almost surreal experience to be
able to sit down with this guy and listen
to his stories.
It was phenomenal."
The instructors at the Bondurant High Performance
Driving School are top class, but at the end
of Bale's training behind the wheel, Nagle
had to hop in a car to see the actor's progress for himself.
It was during this final exam of sorts that
Bale was really put to the test, as Nagle
joined Bale on the track and intentionally
placed pressure on him to see how well he
could hold his composure and focus on the
road.
"If you're gonna push a piece of machinery
to the limit and expect it to hold together,
you have to have some sense of where that
limit is."
Nagle shared:
"The last day of the training, we finished
in real race cars.
One of the tests that I do is to whomever
I'm training is to see how well they stay
focused, to see if I can distract them.
[If] they start paying more attention to my
car then they are their own car, then mistakes
start to happen."
Nagle didn't go easy on Bale just because
he's a big-name actor, either.
He admitted, quote, "I hounded him pretty
hard.
I was inches off his gearbox and trying to
fill his mirrors left and right, doing everything
I could to distract him."
According to Nagle, Bale managed to keep his
cool and complete the task without any punch,
he passed the test with flying colors and,
quote, "never bobbled once."
Nagle praised Bale's professionalism during
training.
He admitted:
"He's hands down the best actor I've ever
trained."
Coming from a pro like Nagle, that's quite
a compliment!
All of that training paid off big when it
came time to shoot Ford v Ferrari.
Thanks to his extensive training, Bale knew
exactly what his car was supposed to be doing
during Ford v Ferrari's race scenes, allowing
him to react accordingly while "driving."
Additionally, his work at the Bondurant High
Performance Driving School actually led to
some real time behind the wheel on screen.
As Nagle shared with Looper:
"Because of the training we did with him,
I felt very comfortable putting Christian
in the car."
So, he did.
Nagle revealed that the times in Ford v Ferrari
when you see Miles, quote, "come screaming
into the pits and jump out of the car, or
jump into the car [and] merge into traffic
that's going 100, 150 miles an hour" aren't
fake, and they're not the work of a stuntman, either.
Nagel confessed:
"That's Christian.
You can't fake that."
Some of the cars used in the movie were remarkably
close to the real things, too, creating an
even greater sense of authenticity.
Nagle explained:
"There's a company called Superformance, and
they're actually licensed to make what they
call continuation copies of the GT40.
We had a few of those."
Yes, that means the cars you see in the movie
have the same engine, a Ford 427, as the one
that Miles actually drove.
And yes, it was just as impressive, and fun,
to handle.
In Nagel's words, it was, quote, "Quite a
beast to drive."
We can only imagine.
"That's more like it!"
Ford v Ferrari is in theaters now.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.